Now that Grant's finally made a decision about which cleaning solution brand to
go with, he's decided to sell all the different products he's marketing in a
package. He's going to sell nozzles and wipers and cleaning solution for one
fabulous deal. Taking all the various costs of creating his products and
shipping them and everything into account, Grant calculates that he'll make a
profit of $1000 for every 60 glasses cleaning sets that he sells. And if he
sells 100 glasses cleaning sets he'll make a profit of $1200, assuming that the
relationship between number of cleaning sets sold and profits is linear, or in
other words lies on a straight line, we should be able to predict, how much of a
profit Grant will make, for any number of glasses cleaning sets that he might
sell. It would be really great if we could plot this information on a graph. And
then use that graph to find out about other points on the line. If we let x
equal the number of cleaning sets that Grant sells and y equal his profit in
dollars, can you write each of these pieces of information as a point on the
line that we're going to be able to draw?